- Let's say hello to
Vanna White everybody.
(upbeat music)
- How are you?
- Oh my gosh! You just look so good,
still I'm angry about it,
I'm so happy for you
is what I meant to say.
(Vanna laughs)
Where are you? Hello!
Where are you at right now?
- I'm sitting in my dressing
room all dressed up for you.
- Okay, I love it, I love it,
I like the shoes behind you.
So do you keep any favorite
things from the show?
- You know, I don't get to keep my dresses
but sometimes they let me
borrow them for things like this
or charity events and
things like that, so yeah,
it's kind of the best
of both worlds, right?
- Yes, it's so much smarter
to just borrow than buy
because you can only wear
it once anyway, generally,
I don't, I re-wear things, talk about it,
I don't care, talk about it.
Yeah, I'm not wasting my
money, it's a nice black dress.
Yeah, oh wait, so after all these years,
do you still love the excitement of it
especially when people like win big money
and it kind of changes their life,
does that still get to you?
- It's wonderful, we have so many winners,
they pay off their student
loans, they buy their first car,
they start a new business, so
there's so many great stories,
it's so great to see people
win and they win big.
- They definitely do.
Do you still remember any
of the big fails as well
when people thought they
were about to kill it
and they didn't?
- Yes, they are so nervous up there.
One of the puzzles was more
fun than a barrel of monkeys,
they said more fun than
a barrel of Vikings.
Another one was gone with the wind
and they said done with one hand.
- No.
(Kelly laughs)
That's not how that goes.
- Oh, next, okay so before
the board was digital,
did you ever turn the wrong letter around?
'Cause that would have kind
of ruined everything.(laughs)
- One time I did it, I was mortified.
I don't even remember which
was the correct puzzle,
it was either Dr. Spock or Mr. Spock
and I turned the M or
the D and it was like,
"Oh that's the wrong letter, oh my gosh!"
So, I'm scarred for life on that.
- Wait, what happens?
Do they have to like throw that one out?
- [Karen] Oh no!
- They did.
They had to throw it out
and put another one in.
- Yeah but one time in 40 years?
- I know I'm like one time only.
- Fortunately in 1997 they
changed the puzzle board
where I only touch the
letters and when I touch them,
I won't touch them unless they light up,
so the mistake will not be mine.
- Oh.
- Oh I love that, yeah, throw
someone else under that bus,
that's what I'd do.
So you're doing "Celebrity
Wheel Of Fortune" now,
so are famous people better or worse
than your usual contestants?
'Cause that was pretty funny,
it took a minute to get
that L out, so...(laughs)
- They're definitely fun,
they have a great time
and I'm really surprised
at how good they really do.
- Oh my gosh! I think I would
be nervous under the pressure
but girl, I'll love some Wheel
of Fortune slot machines.
- I would do it.
- Please tell me, wait, you would do it?
- I would try but I would not
do well, probably nervous.
- I love the Wheel of Fortune.
- Yeah, I do love Wheel of Fortune,
wait, have you ever played,
please tell me you've played
Wheel of Fortune slot machines in Vegas.
- Well, here's the thing, I have played it
but only for a minute
because what if I won,
that would be so weird,
so what I do...
- It would be awesome.
- It would be weird.
- Let me tell you what I do.
When I walk to the casino,
I walk up to a Wheel
of Fortune slot machine
and I'll rub the machine
or I'll tap the person on the
shoulder and say, "Good luck!"
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- And keep on walking.
- Do they freak out?
- And they're like, "What?
Wait, you're Vanna White, what?"
- Wait, you make this
promise to me right now ma'am
'cause I love playing slot machines
and I'm there often
enough when I do events,
so if you ever see me in
Vegas playing Wheel of Fortune
and you don't come up
to me and give me luck,
I will never talk to you again.(laughs)
- I promise I will.
- Okay, I love the(mimicking beep sounds)
(Karen laughs)
and now they've got the gold
spin Vanna, it's so much fun.